today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives to fund the mayo clinic study that
tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus
[Music]
convalescent
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman their
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality
all right okay guys we don't have any
more time for that because we have
so much to discuss and a very very
special stream today i was
initially planning on broadcasting to
you
um a donald trump rally in fayetteville
north carolina
and a joseph r biden jr rally
in tampa florida trump canceled his
rally because it's windy
and trump just having a lot of weather
problems where if you believed in
symbol signs from god you might think
it's too hot
it's too cold it's too windy you might
think god was sending you a message if
you believe that right and that's it
that's a major major if
um but trump has canceled his rally
we have just the joe biden rally and i'm
actually curious whether we'll get any
sizeable audience for this
because a lot of trumpists and
anti-trumpists for different reasons
enjoy watching the trump events
this will be a test of what it might be
like if indeed joseph r biden jr were to
defeat donald trump on tuesday of what
the
post-trump era might be like and we'll
see what kind of an audience we get
we'll see i don't know um but my my
sense is
that there will be interest in hearing
what uh what joseph
has to say today now those of you who
were listening to that song at
the top including samples from jessie
lee peterson there's this explosive
situation with jessie lee peterson where
and i want to be careful with my
language
people are saying he got caught liking
gay porn
caught implies again that there's
something
wrong with being gay but i think what
people are getting at
is jessie lee peterson who claims as a
black conservative christian pastor
um claims to have the moral high ground
because he's
anti-gay and doesn't have sex outside of
wedlock as he told me during an
interview and all of this different
stuff
now he it turns out maybe he
is gay himself which would not be
altogether surprising
but he's constantly talking about alpha
male beta male
and sometimes these guys we've seen it
happen with so many
of these pastors ted haggard comes to
mind and
i don't remember the names of the others
but there's at least a couple dozen
examples of this
um you know when when he when you step
back and it's like he's obsessed with
alpha and beta males and proving how
much of an alpha he is
he's a producer pat today told me i
didn't know this
but i guess jesse jesse told me he's off
sex right now when i interviewed him a
few weeks ago
because he's not in a marriage but i
guess he's not been
in a relationship for since he was a
teenager is that
can anybody tell me whether that's
actually true or not in any case
clearly jesse is a guy who is struggling
and uh i hope that he finds peace
wherever it is that that
is and i don't know anything other than
he um i guess he thought
that likes on twitter maybe aren't
public or something
but he liked gay porn on twitter and
then gave
what i heard was a bizarre explanation
and in fact
if somebody can find his his explanation
uh transmitted a complete lack of
understanding of how twitter works
so if somebody can find that and email
it to me um because links i don't think
will work in the chat
i i would love to take a look at that
because pat told me about it i haven't
heard about it okay
anyway that's jessie lee peterson when
does the
biden event start i don't know it either
starts in 8 minutes or 33 minutes
it's scheduled for two different times i
guess we should be going by the biden
harris
hey you know what's really by the way
the biden harris channel
has this scheduled for 33 minutes from
now
we have way more people watching than
the number of people waiting on the
biden
joe biden's youtube channel doesn't do
that well we may well have
a 10x larger audience on my channels
than joe biden will have
on his own channel which would be
interesting
which would be interesting if that were
the case maybe it starts in eight
minutes
maybe it starts in 33 minutes let me say
just a very quick thank you
to frank derrigo frank derigo is new
member number one today
at join joinpackman.com and i really
appreciate frank's support
let me get to a few super chats that are
coming in
uh dr chakuseki head of david pakman
show radiology department
says i enjoy greek salads so i think i'm
a feta male do you think jessie lee
peterson looks down upon that
hard to say who doesn't enjoy feta on a
greek salad
i i would consider myself a feta male
yeah why not
um charlie says do you think tucker
forgot to check the box this package
contains explosive documents on the air
bill
um yeah i we put out a clip about
the the the damning evidence against
hunter biden being lost in the mail
and then i guess since the clip went out
i'm taking a look here
the clip went out almost two hours ago i
guess ups since
found the evidence if you don't know
what i'm talking about ch check out my
clip about this okay
steve leon says why don't you cover
credible accusations that cut against
biden
i i i will cover the credible
accusations against biden absolutely i
think that's important now
if you're talking about the allegation
that hunter biden
flew three thousand miles drunk to drop
off three laptops
to a blind guy who because he's blind
couldn't actually identify hunter biden
but assumes hunter biden dropped the
laptops off
because there was a bow biden sticker on
one of the laptops
held on to these laptops which hunter
after flying 3 000 miles to drop
off never picked up instead of then
trying to get the laptops back to the
owner he reads hunter's private email
and turns it over to the fbi after the
fbi doesn't do anything with it
the blind repair man who didn't see
hunter biden because he's blind
calls rudy giuliani and says here's the
information
if that's the story you're talking about
it's because it's not credible
okay uh that's the reason why i have and
in fact i have been talking about it as
not credible
all right very good um
serge sambarak says dp do you think
trump will ever do time why or why not
no i don't think trump will do time
because presidents don't go to prison in
the united states
okay i'm not saying it should be one way
or the other i'm just saying
they don't uh and unless that changes
then he won't angkit sethi says did you
check the hilarious deep fake video by
sassy justice
no also shout out to joe woodward's
latest powerful soundcloud track
they like me oh let me check that out i
haven't i haven't heard that from joe
oh wait or is that the one he sent me
that i thought was maybe less of a good
fit for the show
they like me oh yeah yeah yeah i did
okay i'll play this for you guys a
little bit take a listen to it
at the crux of the theory it is this
belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind well i haven't i
haven't heard that but is that supposed
to be a bad thing or a good thing i mean
you
911 was an inside job people in our
government
who are working towards a deep state
we're trying to keep us controlled
[Music]
children are being harvested children
are being farmed
for adrenochrome by celebrities and
politicians
okay all right so that's the new track
from joseph woodward that's featuring
dane hines so it's a collaboration
i like it i don't think it's as natural
of a fit for the show
as for example the plasma song
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the china virus that will
save countless lives okay anyway you
guys know that one already so we won't
uh we'll use them strategically
um samuel wakefield does do it says do i
think tucker
a ups finding tucker's documents with
dirt on joe biden
will be like when comey announced his
investigation on hillary
i don't think it will be like that no i
don't
paperchasen says do you like the movie
hocus pocus
never even heard of it never even heard
of it that's how out of it i am
unknown prodigy says drives me insane
politicians that vote against gay
legislation that are secretly homosexual
can you be any more of a hypocrite
republican
council says will you please tell us the
kfc story
oh man i don't know so here's the deal
i've alluded to this before um
i have not been to a fast food
restaurant that includes
subway that includes obviously the big
three
that even includes places like sabaro
and you know what i have not been to
starbucks i've not been to a fast food
restaurant for
about 18 years but there is what i call
the kfc incident and i've referenced it
before
um i would i'll tell the story i'll tell
the story if we get to 25 members okay
i'll open phone lines if we get to 50
but i'll tell the story if we get to 25
members or patrons it's not i've never
told the story before and it's quite an
embarrassing one
but i will tell the kfc story if we if
we get there
and eli wimmer is new member number two
today
getting us one closer couple updates on
collaborations by the way
um i am now in contact i know i now know
that it's
vash it's not vaush it's not
the osh like a sort of hebrew with the
apostrophe
it's just vosh i'm in contact with him
after his absolutely historic
deconstruction of timothy destiny poole
ii
it's it's truly a remarkable thing and i
encourage everybody to check it out
uh we are trying to figure out how to do
something together because
you know uh i mean i'm not even gonna
say it correctly because
of the twitch situation the osh is not
allowed on twitch right now
so we're looking at doing something like
youtube and facebook only
um and uh for people saying my
dismantling of tim pool was better
i don't think so i appreciate the
compliment i
think vaash did i i want to learn
from vaash how to properly prepare
for for those takedowns because it is it
is something else
it is something else i also today
speaking of collabs
i don't know how many of you are
familiar with the uh program
jane the virgin but the great
mexican american mexican now lives in
the u.s
actor jaime camille fantastic
actor big progressive
found out viewer
of the david pakman show interviewed him
today
in spanish for the spanish show
anesthesia
called in context with david pakman
and he actually during the interview
jaime
did an impersonation of an argentinian
accent it's very very good
it's very good and that'll air on on
cable this weekend
and hopefully next monday or tuesday i
will have a clip
for it of it um for for
the youtube channel maybe for the stream
really really great stuff
um yeah very excited a big booster of
progressive independent media jaime
kamil very very good guy so that was
very exciting
excellent actor absolutely okay good
um let's see what let me just do a
couple of other things i have one meme
for you i don't know how many of you saw
my video on youtube yesterday just
keeping an eye on different streams here
for the biden harris event
i don't know how many of you saw my clip
yesterday about expanding the supreme
court
this came i believe from the subreddit
it is time to pack the court
that is my judgment in favor of the
plaintiff ladies and gentlemen so we've
been a little bit um
we've been a little low on the memes
lately i would like to have more memes
and if you have memes to submit related
to the show stuff like this
the best place is actually the discord
there's a meme
uh sub server forum i don't know what
the right
channel on the discord davidpakman.com
discord
so uh please please please uh submit
your memes
there and then i had one other thing for
you guys
where is it hold on a second
um where is oh oh oh
i have a voicemail i actually don't
remember what this is
i hope it may be unsafe for children i'm
not sure
i bookmarked this yesterday i actually
don't remember what it is let's listen
to it this could be a completely vile
voicemail let's take a listen
what the heck it's not even playing
trickless you're a real
scumbag oh this guy again venezuela
you communist [ __ ]
back to court we're not packing the
court we're
legitimately replacing ruth bader
ginsburger
packing the court is adding more than
nine people you jackass
why don't you take a civics course stick
that mic right up your ass
you stupid [ __ ] you teach
i'd pull my kids out of school if i knew
you were anywhere near them
i'm shocked they're even allowed in
school you're you're more than likely a
a pervert a child molester to you
idiot what do they do you look at their
you wonder what what a little dick looks
like you know because you don't even
have one
you got a [ __ ] you don't even have balls
balls i like that that just gets me
every time
i don't even understand this guy i'm
pretty sure this guy is from maine but
it almost doesn't sound
like a uh like a main accent it's weird
oh that was it okay balls
that's really and that's something else
uh thank you to peter
falstad peter falstad is new member
number three today
at joinpackman.com i guess the deal
we've made is
if we get to 25 website members and
patrons i'm telling the kfc incident
and if we get to 50 i'm opening up the
phone lines we are standing by for
joseph r biden jr in tampa florida
scheduled originally for 6 30 although
the biden harris
youtube channel says that they are still
22 minutes from starting i'm sure it
will start very very soon
okay a couple of other super chats that
i want to read but before i do that
thank you to gooney for the twitch sub
bowflex man hesh done
aldermere poete 2
blake yet stacky oh my god i don't even
know what i'm saying but a lot of these
people are supporting me on twitch which
i appreciate
other super chats coming in jackson says
come on david there's nothing more alpha
than okay i don't want you know if jesse
lee peterson is a gay guy
that's fine that we shouldn't i don't
want to get into anything that may be
sort of like
ridiculing him for being gay that he
should be ridiculed
for being a terrible influence on
american society through his
stupid show that's what he should be
ridiculed for
big thank you to rob hubretz
hubretzi rob hebrezi is new member
number four today
and luke treffery is new member number
five
snugnugs says hey david where do you get
your global news
in high school ap comparative government
opened my eyes to the world but haven't
found a suitable way to keep up since
then
love the show you know i read a lot of
global history
but i actually don't keep up as much
with global news as i would like
because i'm so busy with my own show so
i don't have anything in particular to
recommend to you
ken says remember biden harris are only
step zero simply hitting reset isn't a
silver bullet
right the analogy i use to to winning
is they've had the ball
for the last four years we now want to
get the ball back
then you've got to do something with the
ball you've actually got to put points
on the board and joe biden winning
just gets the ball back then you've got
to do something with it
rather than turn it over steve
says tony bobolinsky made a credible
allegation you ignore come on guys
come on nicholas bowers his friendly
greetings from the 603 that's uh that's
new hampshire i think right
tristan says doc's clearing jlp scandal
were lost by fedex
exactly danny says wait how did the
blind guy read the emails
presumably some kind of text to speech
right
that would be my guess waffle says
german officials are considering sending
election observers to the u.s as they
did with nigeria previously
they'd wait for an invitation though i
would love international observers of
this election
i i would love it i think i think it
makes sense i think we should have it
um let me see unknown prodigy says akam
akham's razor is on one side of the
universe the hunter biden emails on the
other well said
daddy ron says plasma eriksen says
love the garcetti video en context
new info okay so here's the deal i host
the spanish show once a week
it's a half hour show it's on a network
that many refer to as
estrella because i'm from argentina i
say trisha
and it is sundays 4 pm eastern 1 p.m
pacific
check local listings only on in about 45
cable markets coming to the internet
soon
but i've been uploading some of the
interviews
to the youtube channel um
dss dze says aloha david from hawaii our
entire family watches your channel
including our teenage sons keep it up
mahalo thank you ivan says david just
wanted to say hi from your home country
i'm sure you'll recognize the currency i
know it's not much but it's what i can
do
i can appreciate that um 50 argentinian
pesos let me see
50 ars t what is the exchange rate now
64 cents
the exchange rate is brutal brutal right
now
um usd to ours
so the official exchange rate now has
fallen to 78 pesos per dollar
but there's also the blue dollar which i
think is worth only
150 or rather the paid it's 150 pesos
per dollar roughly
it is toxic what is going on with
currency in argentina it's i don't even
know i i just don't even understand how
it works even remotely
it's completely insane uh oliver says
david i mailed you damning documents
that prove hillary is hunter biden's
twin vampire sister
and the last remaining decepticon
hopefully they don't get lost in the
mail yeah they might vanish
the detestor says your channel has
opened my eyes to the fact that our
future kids will one day learn about
this presidency in history class they
will have questions
i hope they do i hope they do
big thank yous to sabrina sanoa
who is new member number six julietta
johnson is new member number seven
oliver klosov is new member number eight
deborah lashua is number nine
milo aviles is number 10 alex kolchisky
is number 11 and emmanuel sparvoli is
number 12.
yeah i promise to tell the kfc story if
we get to 25 new members
um okay
let me um oh i had a cup so
i at the risk of losing my mind laughing
donald trump did a bunch of different
rallies yesterday
and i have i was laughing all night
just sitting there watching trump have
uh audio problems
um i don't know what was going on with
the audio for trump's speech yesterday
but you've got to listen to this and
what's funny is how pissed off trump
gets it's the best of you states
[Laughter]
oh man i love how it throws them off
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh now it's probably a rhino is
operating
and then this next one really got me
listen to this
[Music]
these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for once i i
don't know why i find this so funny
but i find it endlessly funny my my i
was laughing so hard last night i was
crying and my girlfriend actually
just came into my office and filmed me
laughing hysterically at these
let's just look at it one more time i
just love it
[Music]
[Applause]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
no it's probably a rhino is operating
they're having a bad day today they're
having a bad day but we're having a good
day
oh man let's just look at this one one
more time this is this is the best
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
[Applause]
whoever did this microphone don't pay
him
we know he regularly doesn't pay uh
i just i love that i don't know why but
i find it to be
the absolute funniest thing
um okay all right so we're off of that
oh i guess just because we're not
because trump canceled his evening rally
let me just look at a couple of clips
from the earlier rally that he did
in tampa i guess melania was talking
about
getting rid of hate and negativity which
is bizarre given that
she's married to trump
[Applause]
in a time when hate negativity
and fear are the messages the media
streams
into our homes and the large tech
companies
are protecting political censorship we
need to remember
what is really important right my
husband's administration
is focused on the future
i mean it's just it's it's
indistinguishable from parity
um at a packed rally melania says
trump's focused on destroying the virus
this president and his team are focused
on not only destroying the virus and
building back the economy
they're focused on the creating ways for
people to safely stop
isolating and start gathering with
friends again
on a safe distances right and i don't
know if that's even off the prompter if
she's riffing there
um we'll never lock down again
no masks visible oh i guess trump did a
sur routine
where's hunter is hunter in the crowd
[Applause]
they don't call him out
they don't call them out on where's
[Applause]
hunting
ah it's crazy that's crazy you know some
people said i get a call from all the
experts
right guys that ran for president six
seven eight times
never got past the first round but
they're calling me up sir you shouldn't
be speaking about hunter
sir uh okay major criminality he should
be prosecuted
okay don't really care about that trump
says bad things will happen to the
whistleblower
lock him up about joe about joe biden
we're used to that
russia russia russia oh and i guess okay
let's see these are trump's latest
fabricated attacks on biden
sir look what he's doing in philadelphia
look what what's happening those are
people that
he's supporting he couldn't even come
out against him yesterday they asked him
a question
he said uh what's philadelphia where is
it
he didn't know what state it was in that
didn't happen other than that he's doing
a wonderful job could you imagine
could you imagine losing to this guy
could you imagine well let's see
our first lady will have to say darling
i don't know what this is
darling i thought she was referring to
trump as sir now as well
uh okay here's trump's explanation of
why he'll win minnesota which he won't
characters that like ilhan omar i'm
going to win
minnesota because of ilhan omar
she tells us how to run our country
she taught us how to run our country i
don't think so ilhan
isn't she american no she's not she's an
immigrant right okay no
i forget which of the squad members are
american she's she's an american citizen
now
so we're going to win the state of
minnesota for two reasons her
and the fact that when minneapolis had
their problem they should have called us
sooner but when they called us
how long did it take 25 minutes it was
extinguished
we could have done it the first hour
you know it's almost better instead of
spending 75 minutes watching the rally
we could just watch a few clips you know
what i'm saying guys i think that that
that may be an idea
um trump rails on china we can skip that
trump under counts the death toll by 15
000 okay
someone sprays water into the air and
trump says are their friend or foe okay
so i guess he's threatening people in
the crowd let's see
mike pence has not made hundreds of
millions of dollars by scamming foreign
countries
[Music]
because that's what they've done they've
made hundreds of millions
of dollars and they can't and nobody
wants to talk about look at that
oh are they doing that on purpose
are they friend or foe
i don't actually felt good i felt water
on my face i said where the hell is that
[Applause]
they may be doing that on purpose let's
find out if they're friend or foe
and if their phone let's take care of
their son of a [ __ ]
the proper phrase is sons of [ __ ] but
you know what what can i say all right i
think that's enough of that guy so
anyway
a completely normal rally in the sense
that it's completely abnormal and needs
to be
eliminated immediately i see people in
the chat
awaiting the kfc uh incident
um wondering how could i have not have
been to a starbucks in 18 years
very easily i don't how have you been to
a starbucks very easy to avoid starbucks
all right james burke is new member
number 13 today
christopher strom is new member number
14.
jude neil is new member number 15.
foom duke is new member number 17
kyle marathu is new member number 18 and
tammy lamb
is new member number 19. beautiful
listen
i i i'll actually just tell the kfc
story now because i think people would
enjoy it
i'll switch our goal to 50. i'll tell
i'm going to give you the kfc story
you're going to be underwhelmed
but if we do get to 50 i will open the
discord phone lines okay here's the kfc
story
all right i have not been to a fast food
restaurant at famously this is what i'm
most famous for much more than the david
pakman show i've not been to a fast food
restaurant for about 18 years
this means no mcdonald's no burger king
no wendy's no
taco bell no um subway
no uh you know none none of this stuff
just
none of it okay you understand when i
was about
23 maybe i was living in northampton
massachusetts
the old stomping grounds of the show and
a kfc opened up in northampton
massachusetts after there having been no
kfc
in the area for a very long time and
there was a sort of nostalgic thing i
remember when i moved to the united
states with my family
uh we we okay we went to a kfc and i
remember
you know getting getting the chicken
pieces and i would love the coleslaw and
the mashed potatoes and the sporks and
the entire thing okay
so the kfc opens up and i've already got
years in with no fast food whatsoever
and i broke down and i went to the kfc
i got a crispy strip meal with the
coleslaw with the mashed potatoes
uh it was absolutely fantastic and then
i never went back and so when i say
that it was a fugue state of sorts i
think it's fair to say it's sort of like
the fugue state in
uh breaking bad except real and so when
i say i famously never been to a fast
food restaurant in 18 years and all this
different stuff
i am skipping the kfc story because it's
like
if every time i say except for the one
time i went to kfc
it sort of devalues the story it makes
it a less dramatic story
but that is the kfc incident which was
it was a fugue state i don't know how
else to say it but i think we're going
to call it a fugue state and chalk it up
to that and that's it
um and other than that no mcdonald's no
no fast food starbucks stuff
i have not i've always been able to find
a local coffee shop okay local coffee
shop
no starbucks whatsoever i'm not into
uh i'm not into that ultra dark greasy
you know extremely burnt coffee beans
i'm more of a
medium light roast type of guy so
starbucks is just not for me i know now
they've put together some bs light roast
stuff give me a break guys
okay that's enough let's move on i i do
have a bunch of other super chats let me
get to some twitch thank yous first
um keter says what a great gift for my
six-month celebration the kfc story
exactly
exactly post happy streams has also
gifted a subscription
and sally annette and gooney bowflex man
have all subscribed and it's
very very exciting very very exciting
what is happening
we are down to presumably our last five
minutes before the start of this joe
biden event
i am i am committing that we had such a
great time when we opened up the phone
lines on i believe
it was tuesday that i am willing to open
up the phone lines
uh and postpone my dinner if we do get
to 50 website members i will do it
now thanks to andre
who is new member number 20 and luke
bourgeon who is new member number 21
we are getting close as a reminder i
would really
love it and appreciate it if you did
grab a membership on my website
joinpakman.com it's really cheap
it's 66 cheaper if you use the coupon
code 2020 now
which we are eliminating on election day
and i will do my best to thank every
single person who signs up
uh and maybe we'll get some phone lines
open all right i am getting word
via twitch chat that we have a new
record of cases today
uh okay according to world domiters
we're
at 81 000 but this may be delayed
i'm being told we're actually at is that
82
um or 88 88.5
says the virtual fat ass what does any
webs do you guys know what website
has it at 88 000 today yeah in a day yes
anybody know what website has that
number
we don't know we're not sure
like let's see if i refresh 89.54 still
89 54 here
all right so we may have to wait for
this website to update but
somewhere between 81 000 and 88
000 cases today uh the other thing i did
want to show you guys
is the early voting numbers are
unbelievable
almost 81 000 votes have already been
cast
of those 28 million are in person and 52
million
are by mail uh if you look at turnout as
a percentage of 2016
texas is already 95 of the way to its
total
2016 turnout it's unbelievable
other states with very strong turnout
montana at 85 percent
oregon and and washington at 82.
uh vermont 73
um tennessee in the 80s north carolina
in the 80s georgia
so a lot of these states all oh and and
uh hawaii
has look at hawaii five
percent more people have already voted
in hawaii than the total from 2016
and importantly when you look at the
parties stuff we've got to be really
really careful with this data
because only some states report the
party data
so from what we know the votes so far
are 47 percent from democrats
the in-person votes republicans are
winning by five the mail-in votes for
democrats are winning by 24 but it's
partial data
this means nothing everybody must vote
everybody must must must vote that is
the only message
all right thank you very much thanks to
aaron kaner
who is new member number 22 today all
right let me get back to super chats
because i know i've fallen
behind matthew chouinard says what do
you think of joe rogan having alex jones
on for four hours the week before an
election to peddle crap conspiracies
about hunter biden's laptop
giving the conspiracy credibility the
entire podcast again the next day i'm
against it
i'm against it i think it's uh i i don't
think it's responsible platforming and
i'd be glad to talk to joe about that
any time
crystal rosario says am i the only one
that gets jim jones jonestown vives when
trump says he's leaving if he loses as
if he's testing the trumpets very
cultish vibes
absolutely check out my interview with
stephen hassan
about trumpism as a cult very very
important interview skunk games says
maynar here that sounds way more like a
long island accent to me
you can tell by the balls yeah
steven says trying to read the tea
leaves in florida miami-dade over 53
of registered voters have voted early
orange county 50 percent hillsboro 53
if there is 70 percent turnout in these
three
florida could go blue indeed
christopher scott says five dollars says
your pants filled with gravy
my god i hope that was worth five
dollars we've got a real problem in this
country
truth squad says you have to talk about
the jesse lee peterson situation i did
at the top of the show
uh you can rewind and go back to the uh
go back to the top of the show kadara 77
has subscribed with twitch prime
says what do you think about the supreme
court decisions about mail-in ballot
deadlines for north carolina and
pennsylvania
that were made we covered that on
today's bonus
show so i try to avoid doing the same
content twice in a day so get that bonus
show my friends
i am seeing requests i'm seeing special
requests that today
out of desperation to open the phones we
count twitch subs towards
the goal i would be willing to do that
today
but the goal has to be more than 50. i'd
be willing to count twitch subs
if we make the goal a hundred total and
then twitch subs website subs
and patreon will all count what do
people say do we do it or do we stick
with the goal we have
i am i am at your command
some people asking for 90. i don't know
about 90. 90 is not a round number
you guys want to do it all right so
we're going to do it so 100
website let's do it website members
and i'll change this to twitch
boom all right there we go so it counts
and i'm going to make a note
twitch is at 12.50 because this is going
to be hard to keep track of
twitch is at 12.50 so like now it's 12
51.
so that gets us to well now hold on now
i've got to remember how many i've
counted this is going to get complicated
how am i going to do this i'll just sort
of keep track separately twitch is at
what was that we started twitch at 12
50. all right so let's just keep that in
mind very good
um okay other super chats coming in
epic fail says fellow mainer here we do
not claim
that man yeah i uh that i understand
i understand um uh oh
jackson says to be clear i'm not
ridiculing him for being gay i fall on
that side of the fence as well
just ridiculing his hypocrisy and the
alpha beta nonsense fair yeah that that
i think makes sense
uh jennifer says if biden wins do you
have concerns about a potential mass
shooting at any inauguration event i
fear for biden and any attendees
the inauguration itself will be very
safe my fear is more about um
violence in the streets that that's more
my fear
drunk emma says feeling very optimistic
winning by a landslide
christopher says if jessie lee peterson
put a stamp in a trap he would be bait a
male and it would be amazing
okay eric says any thoughts on trump's
department of interior delisting wolves
today
is it something that can be quickly
overturned i haven't heard of that so i
wouldn't be able to say
edith asks whether trump refers to aids
as the african virus
i've never heard him do that no
semi-truck driver says hey david i've
become a big fan of yours over the past
few years
have you ever thought about starting a
whack pack i think we have one
i think we have one um let me see
so we had let me see if i can do this
uh so this guy would certainly be on it
i don't know if you heard this earlier
i'll just replay this voicemail
this guy is certainly in the whack pack
hey prickles you're a real
scumbag why don't you go back to the
venezuela
you communist [ __ ]
back to court we're not packing the
court we're
legitimately replacing ruth bader
ginsburger
packing the court is adding more than
nine people you
jackass why don't you take a civics
course
stick that mic right up your ass you
stupid [ __ ]
so that guy definitely is in the whack
pack this is troy york who's also this
guy calls me five times a day desperate
to get on
uh take a listen to this one yes uh
david peckman uh this is york
troy here um i don't know i i didn't
hear you mention it on your program
today but
um senator ted cruz and
ohio so he didn't hear it on the program
today he called it 3 20 in the morning
and the hearings he's referencing were
happening after
we filmed yesterday's show i mean it's
just wacky
um congressman jim jordan they totally
eviscerated
uh jack dorsey of twitter
um behind censorship and his
prevention of spreading the uh
sexual story of hunter biden anyway and
then he immediately called back
yeah um the psychopath of you guys
talking about
packing the courts will never occur
as it is an attack on our checks and
balances and
pretty much the constitution and it's
not anyway it's so boring but he's
desperate to get on he'll sometimes call
in and pretend to be
a black guy named jamal once he
pretended to be a hispanic guy named
ramon ramos uh of course
you know he's talking about ramos uh
it's it's crazy it's completely crazy
um i do think that there's probably
something going on
mental health-wise yeah okay
um sebastian brown says on chomsky
endorsement you said
most sense he's made in a long time has
never made more sense
yet he's always advocating voting
democrats over republicans clarify
yeah the i just think the clarity with
which he distilled
distilled down the absurdity of like a
bernie or bus
type mentality i had not heard that from
gnome
previously all right let's get caught up
on member numbers we've got kyle zoll
who's number 23
fabian triffen who's number 24
sean reed is number 25 and jamie kieffer
is number 26. now i also said
uh twitch subs would count as of 12.50
so now we're at 12.76 so i'll make a new
note
that also gets us plus 26 to 52.
you understand guys all right i'm i'm
able to keep track of it you guys did
not trust my arithmetic skills
but we're able to keep track of it okay
um oh and here we go the event will
begin shortly
beautiful um all right so
i see some some interesting posts about
why do people
hate watch the david pakman show i don't
know
i really don't know there's two things i
don't understand about viewers
if you really hate me that much just
watch something else you know
what why even bother with what i'm doing
it's like i'm not i'm not that important
watch something else
and also there's a group of people it's
very small
but there's a group of people in the
audience who have a level of entitlement
that is crazy to me that would never
occur to me like i got a message the
other day from someone who said
hey david um you know i sort of like
what you're doing
but i'm a little bit concerned that
you're saying you
voted powerfully it's kind of turning me
off
and unless you can explain to me what
that means i don't know that i'm going
to watch anymore
like dude it's it's just a joke trump
says he's doing this powerfully and very
strongly
so i said you know as a whim on a whim
on a stream the other day
oh i voted very powerfully here's the
video it's like
if i watched you know if i watch a show
and there's a joke i don't like
or maybe just i just don't watch the
show anymore it would never occur to me
to demand an answer from like it's
it's it's a level of presumptuousness
and i know a lot of people are saying
these are just millennials no some of
these are older folks some of them are
me
it's all ages that this happens another
one i got there was another one recently
i
i was just what was the other one
someone said oh damn i did
it's such a good example and i don't
remember it
um anyway if i if i remember it i'll
mention it to you guys
okay the event is going to begin shortly
um in tampa florida very good
serge says i was told that if the race
is close trump could use the supreme
court to help him win is this true well
what he what donald trump is going to
try to do he's admitting that he's going
to try to do it what donald trump could
try to do
is to appeal to the court to stop the
counting of absentee ballots after
midnight
at the end of november 3rd using
different rationale
in different states he's already
admitted he's going to try to do it
so that's how the supreme court could
potentially get involved
sarah says governor walls called in the
state national guard not trump
good um
love and music says two first-time
voters here for biden we are 33 and 38.
love it love it you guys know what's
insane
um there's only a thousand people
watching this on joe biden's actual
youtube
channel and there's ten thousand people
watching it on my streams right now
i don't know if that's good or bad it
doesn't sound that good
it doesn't sound that good to me thanks
to andreas
nilsson who is new supporter
53 today and we also
have four more on twitch
which gets us to 57. we made
i made a deal with the devil today where
we would include twitch subs in our
goal to open the phone lines but the
goal is a hundred
and we're at 57. this is all this is
your deal guys
this is your deal you you you and push
this on me
and i agreed to it bryce weech says
those mike boops reminded me of vic
berger
of trump where the air horns go off all
the time you rock david yeah let's just
look at it just one more time
i was cracking up yesterday watching the
audio problems trump was having at his
rally
and i think what makes it funny is how
upset trump gets take a look
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
these guys yeah that's right you can't
maybe uh
no it's probably a rhino and then just
moments later it happened again and
trump said the
these people don't know what the hell
they're talking about and are incredible
oh these people don't know what the hell
they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second
then later he says that the audio
engineers shouldn't be paid
so that's uh that's a nice touch
obviously um
okay yeah someone wrote to me saying
david uh the audio engineers are really
doing god's work there
okay we things are happening my friends
let's make sure we get to hd
um this is a voter mobilization event
from tampa florida what's going on here
i don't know what the hell is happening
here um let's just
listen to a moment but mostly we're
going to be listening to joe biden
[Music]
all right good evening tampa bay
let me hear some noise come on come on
tampa bay good evening very high energy
chloe coney but until november the first
i'm changing my memory the audio is
completely out of sync let me just
refresh and see if that remains man
everything going wrong here
vote early okay
i am growing so the audio being out of
sync is not on my end i'm just letting
you guys know
i helped to integrate the school system
here you heard
congresswoman caster talk about that
okay so we're gonna we're waiting for
joe biden i want to keep hearing from
you guys for the time being
michael with a 20 super chat says
starbucks coffee sucks anyway dave yeah
that's i don't go to starbucks guys come
on
uh you know i i am not going to
participate in the burnt coffee i'm just
not doing
it i'm not doing it i'm not doing it i'm
not doing it very very much
not happening haven't been to a
starbucks in 18 years um
plan to keep it that way okay colin
underwood says oh so
you doesn't eat the sadness away must be
nice
i eat my emotions and from 2016 to now i
am emotional david thanks for all you do
carlos says what's your preferred
grocery store um
depends for what uh some i like going to
trader joe's
because they have certain
non-perishables which i love
or or i guess what i would call
semi-perishables where you get you know
a couple months
uh the pastrami smoked salmon is
tremendous at trader joe's you know
they've got all sorts of
jarred jalapenos that i like keeping on
hand for sandwiches and all sorts of
different things
uh produce and fish i'm usually getting
like at whole foods
um or maybe uh and then there's sort of
some local
uh small there's like i i hate this term
but it's like
it's the term they use it's a latino
market it's such a stupid term like
all it really means is like the
employees are hispanic i don't even know
what it why it's
called that but i love going in there um
you know
speaking spanish with all the employees
and they've got a lot of really good
stuff they don't call it a bodega
here that's really a new york term
um but uh yeah anyway
and it's it's big i think it's bigger
than typically what the bodega is
but okay you know let's i don't want to
get into that specifically
but yeah i'm going to different places i
also do a lot of grocery delivery
things i can get delivered i will get
delivered sean says when your coupon
code expires will the cost go up by a
record-breaking 68
exactly yeah you clearly understand the
gdp numbers from today
jessica says my 10 year old son aiden is
a
huge fan keep going thank you
thank you i really appreciate that aiden
uh
i i hope that you are uh watching now
and that you will be with us for the
stream gary says
david oh david
yeah so i like soccer i don't really i
don't follow um
league play i just follow the world cup
and
um copa america just the the argentinian
um national team is really all i follow
matthew says david would you support
carl pilkington as biden's labor
secretary
uh no isn't carl pilkington a comedian i
i don't remember who is carl pinkington
pink pilkington again i don't even
remember unc
says my producer lost the tape of tucker
carlson's first interview at fox
when rupert murdoch showed him why he's
nicknamed the sledgehammer i fired them
how is tucker not fired for losing
documents
couldn't tell you couldn't tell you but
a very very good question
simon says where did that go lost
simon's message
simon says what do you think of
conservatives of conservatives
conspiracy on biden huge fan by the way
i think it lacks credibility
hey david they should change the name of
narcissistic personality disorder to
donald trump
smh shake my head i'm one of the votes
in hawaii
okay very good and griselda
says david can you read all new member
names in espanol please
no i can't that's that's crazy
oliver says what scares him more than
the republican voter fraud
is the successful republican fraud
we have not heard of yes of course
of course can you play the viral ossoff
purdue smackdown while we wait i haven't
seen it
if someone sends it to me i could do it
um all right let's see where we are
as far as members go sean wegner is new
member number 58
and jeremy s stepp is new member number
59
and then we're adding twitch we're at
1289.
we previously were at 1276. that is
another
13 putting us at 72
72 phone lines open
at 100. uh what will the
lincoln project do if biden is elected
just go back to being republicans and
complaining about the debt and deficit
essentially uh all right now we have
someone else coming on let's see what
else is happening here
[Music]
there's joseph r biden jr very good all
right so the event is getting going
um yes
very much so
high energy
[Music]
hello tampa
[Applause]
thank you so much chloe by the way i
continue to think
biden needs less reverb on the mic this
isn't a you know it's not a music
concert
great to see you all thanks for so many
of you being here
as my mother would say god love you all
chloe thanks for sharing your story and
by the way i know the audio's out of
sync i've refreshed
let me just check if we're having the
same issue here
[Music]
oh this is better okay congratulations
turning abandoned buildings and
buildings and dangerous lots into places
of life and hope
making sure that bringing the community
together to build homes
for local families and helping young
people around tampa learn job skills
instill
pride and purpose in neighborhoods that
have been left behind
and laying the groundwork for economic
opportunities endures
through generations that's the sort of
work
that changes the world so thank you
chloe
thank you
i also want to thank all the other
speakers here tonight
including your remarkable mayor jane or
something else kid
thanks for the passport into town i
appreciate it
[Applause]
and my friends and here they are my
friends congressman charlie crist
john you were there in the beginning
charlie thank you pal
thank you thank you thank you right and
kathy castor
her district i sought permission to come
she said okay
thanks kath and alan cohn
who we've got to send to congress
i just spent some time with one of my
best buddies
a guy i served with for a long time in
the united states senate
bill nelson right i haven't served
with anyone with more character courage
and decency than bill
and his daughter nan and his son billy
as well as amazing grace was with him
she's something else isn't she look
folks five days left
five days but who's counting right
but who's counting scranton
i got a scranton sign here i don't know
man
i'm i'm getting wilmington i'm getting
confused here man
millions of americans have already voted
over 75 i'm told 75 million
and millions more are going to vote
before this is over
and i believe when you use your power
the power of the vote we literally are
going to change the course of this
country for generations to come
we're going to do it both at home and
abroad
right here in florida with all of you
you're the ones who built this country
ceos on wall street didn't build this
country you did
come on man not a joke i've been saying
this for years middle middle-class
people did
hard-working folks and unions built the
middle class
i might add and you're the ones going to
save this country
look i said i got in this race for three
reasons a year ago
a little over a year and i meant it the
first was
to restore the soul of this country this
is not who we are
it's not who we are we're more decent
honorable
we're more respectful we're better
people
than we're being seen from this
administration second reason was
to restore the backbone of this country
the middle class
and bring everybody along this time
and thirdly to unite this country
we have to unite us in these final days
keep that sense of empowerment with you
that sense of optimism
what we can do what we can overcome
that's the god's truth i've never been
more optimistic about america and
america's chances than i am today
because i know the american people i
know who we are
we have never ever ever ever let the
country down given a chance
on november 3rd we're going to unite
this country and show the world
who america really is
i mean it i know it's hard
over these past few months has been so
much pain
so much suffering so much loss in
america
more than 225 000 people
dead 225 000.
the estimates are if we reacted
responsibly
there'd be 160 000 fewer dead than there
are today
because of covet 19 we're now past
the nine million mark of people infected
more than sixteen thousand for liver
excuse me
sixteen thousand people in florida have
been lost
and millions of people are out of work
on the edge
they can't see the light at the end of
the tunnel it's like that old bad joke
of my generation
it's a freight train because that's what
happens if he stays in office
donald trump has given up over the
weekend the white house chief of staff
said and i'm quoting
we're not going to control the pandemic
it's obvious he's not at the debate last
week with trump
he said we're we're rounding the corner
it's going away we're wanting to live
with it
remember what i told him he's asking us
to learn to die with it
that's what's happening donald trump has
waived the white flag abandoned our
families
and surrendered to this virus but the
american people
never give up we never give in
and we surely don't cower and neither
will i
[Applause]
donald trump just had a super spreader
event here again
you're spending more more than just
coronavirus he's spreading division
and discord we need a president going to
bring us together
not pull us apart i'll put a
plan a place to deal with this pandemic
responsibly
i'll put in plan of place isn't so good
around testing tracing masking
leading doctors in america including
trump's own cdc director
and dr fauci last week said
that if we just wore a mask between now
and the end of the year we'd save a
hundred
thousand lives folks
that's not a political statement it's a
patriotic duty for god's sake
but still donald trump refuses to listen
to science
and we shouldn't be politicizing the
race for a vaccine
we should be planning for its safe use
and free and equitable distribution
providing ppe for national standards for
schools
businesses open safely i led on a plan
back in may how to do that
bringing together republicans and
democrats to deliver economic relief
that's already been passed by the
democratic house of representatives for
working families
for schools and businesses i've said it
before
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm not going to shut down the country
i'm going to shut down the virus right
[Applause]
you know donald trump
inherited a strong economy from economy
from barack and me
just like he inherited everything in his
life
nice oh it's a fact
he squandered that economy like he
squandered everything else
but folks i promise you
i guarantee you we can build back and
build back better with an economy that
rewards work
not wealth and we can do it without
raising taxes
a single solitary penny on working class
or middle-class families i guarantee you
my word is abide
no one making less than four hundred
thousand dollars will pay
a single penny more in taxes not a penny
but i tell you what i'm going to do and
i make no apologies for it
i'm going to ask the wealthiest
americans and the biggest corporations
of the fortune 500 companies 91
making a collective billions of dollars
didn't pay a
single solitary penny in federal tax
but i'm going to make sure they pay
their fair share
why should a firefighter an educator
a nurse pay a higher rate
than a super wealthier corporate america
because you do
you do why should you pay more taxes
than donald trump pays right
[Applause]
you know if we made this as a movie ten
years ago i think people would think we
were making it up
but it's true powerful message from all
over deliver tax relief for working
families in the middle class
to help you buy your first home help you
pay for health care premiums
for child care for caring for your age
and loved ones for eliminating college
debt
we're going to take care of this and we
can afford it
look trump got his supreme court justice
and he did it for one overwhelming
reason something he's been trying to do
since the day he got elected
to destroy the affordable care act
he's going at it again if they get their
way
100 million americans will lose
predictions for pre-existing conditions
cancer all diseases that are out there
folks look 8.4 million floridians
have pre-existing conditions
complications to covet 19
will become the next pre-existing
condition allowing insurers to jack up
your premiums
deny your coverage a lot of you young
people don't even realize it but
before we pass the affordable care act
insurance companies charge women more
for the same health care
as men just because they were women the
fact
donald trump thinks health care is a
privilege i think it's your right
[Applause]
if we all get out and vote we'll not
only restore obamacare we'll strengthen
and build on it
so you can keep your private insurance
if you like it
and you can choose a medicare-like
option if you don't
we're going to increase subsidies lower
your payments and deductibles and
premiums
out-of-pocket spending reduce
the unknown billing reduce prescription
drug costs by according to the experts
up to
60 by allowing not making this stuff
up by allowing medicare to negotiate for
drug prices
we're going to make sure you keep the
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions
we're going to protect social security
and medicare which they've been trying
to cut for years
meanwhile the social security actuary
the guy who runs it says the plan like
donald trump says
he wants to institute if he gets
reelected he says we'll bankrupt
social security by 2023 as my wife would
say
google it you'll see what i'm telling
you
tell you got that right pal
i said trump trump is bankrupt by the
way he probably is he owes 400 million
dollars of somebody anyway
oh man we have to vote we have to vote
for our military families
google it no not a joke
folks of all the things donald trump has
said
nothing has bothered me worse than the
way he's spoken to those who served in
uniform
they call them losers and suckers
my deceased son beau biden
who won the bronze star the kaspers
service medal in other awards
volunteered to go to iraq for a year
gave up his attorney's general job to go
with his unit he wasn't a sucker or
loser he was a patriot
like all of you served like your sons
your daughters
[Applause]
your parents and your grandparents we
have to vote for their dignity
imagine thinking trump respects the
military
we have to vote because while donald
trump fails
to condemn white supremacy we can
deliver
racial justice while he's trying to make
it worse
look donald trump
doesn't believe that systemic racism is
a problem
he won't save like black lives matter
we know they matter that's why a season
of protest has broken out across the
nation
but by the way protesting
is not burning or looting violence must
never be a tactic tolerated and it won't
but these problems he can say that trump
will still say that biden
endorses or foments violence i mean it's
you know
it doesn't matter but it's good that
he's saying that not by me
not by us not by this country
[Applause]
when i met with the family
his little daughter said looked at me
she's only about seven years old
and i knelt down to talk to her in the
family
she looked at me she said mr vice
president
my daddy is changing the world
well guess what the inspiration
coming from her daddy and what happened
this new wave of justice in america but
true justice is also
more than just dealing with abuse
it's about economic justice it's about
schools housing access to capital
good paying jobs a minimum wage of a
minimum of 15 dollars an hour
financial stability
giving families of color a real shot to
own their own home start a small
business
send a child to college debt-free so we
can build wealth and pass on
opportunities through generations
like we did like so many middle-class
families have in the past
but we have to vote to ensure the full
promise of this country
we have to vote to meet the challenge of
climate crisis
because you know in florida it is a
crisis
we're all seeing the impact more than
most devastating hurricanes that lay
waste to whole communities
economic toll is astounding and it grows
every year
but the human toll was worse lost lives
lost homes small businesses shattered
first responders put a risk from the
west coast burning
the middle part of the country flooding
donald trump when he thinks climate
change he says hoax
well guess what speaking of hoaxes
remember what he said about these
increasing violent hurricanes and the
frequency
he actually said maybe we should
detonate a nuclear bomb over the
atlantic
by the way the same stable geniuses said
the biggest problem we had in the
revolutionary war is we didn't have
enough airports
whoa
yo man i tell you what look
his answers to families in puerto rico
struggling through hurricane maria
was the was what would he do toss rolls
of paper towels at them
they actually shot him like basketball
doesn't have any real answers
but we know we can do something about it
while combating climate change means
jobs we can unleash american ingenuity
and manufacturing and build
a stronger and more climate resistant
nation creating millions of new
high-paying jobs
we can change the path we're on we've
got to act
now time is running out this country
can't afford
former years of trump who thinks he's
only responsible the people who voted
for him
i don't see the presidency that way i
see the america as an american
i'll run as a proud democrat but guess
what
it's starting to rain and i'm going to
shorten this for you all
i don't see america that way in 2018 you
place your trust in barack and me
well guess what each day we were in
office
we worked for you the entire country it
was never about red states or blue
states always about
the united states of america
i was reminded of that last month when i
visited gettysburg folks
you know what when i went to gettysburg
to make that speech abraham lincoln said
a house divided cannot stand
well a nation divided cannot stand
really raining now reminded that earlier
this week
ladies and gents oh god i
oh my god and signal loss has been
detected ladies and gentlemen we have a
blue screen
let's switch back to i guess let's
switch over here now with the unsynced
audio
i forgot what president kennedy said
about going on the moon
he said we're going you know why because
we
refuse to postpone let's not postpone
and get out of the rain
god bless you all thank you wow it's
pouring
[Music]
wow what a day
[Music]
and off goes joe biden
look at that facility with which he just
goes right down the steps
not gingerly uh beautiful beautiful
beautiful
oh my goodness
[Music]
now we're back on this other side uh a
lot of crazy things happening here and
the rain is coming down
very very strongly uh really really
incredible stuff
um okay let's see uh we didn't get to
our goal of a hundred website members
and twitch
subs which was where i had set it
uh to open the phone lines i could
theoretically i do have a little bit of
time let me just see what's going on
with dinner here
um see what we've got i'll read a couple
other super chats i i guess i would
i would do some calls if we get there oh
my god what is it's just everything's
getting crazy now it's don jr
this is all completely nuts wish i
understood what was going on
um in any case some other super chats
here
skunk says trumpers in the chat are
salty the rally got cancelled and it's
too windy for their fuhrer
john saw maintenance put the ventilators
back in a whole row
in a whole row of room windows at the
hospital the past week icu
doubled its cases vote very
very important very very important
elizabeth saying coherent thoughts and
complete sentences
are so refreshing they really are
the douche from ipanema says hey david
if trump wins will you move to quebec
it's hard to move to quebec i don't
think i could i don't i don't know
legally how i could do it
um a very strong hundred dollar super
chat from oliver wilde
who said to all those who do not plan to
vote how dare you stand by
while countless americans and families
worldwide
struggle and fight every day for a
better life
go out and vote yes
and then david with a very disturbing
message
what are your thoughts on what to expect
if trump loses and his crazy supporters
start a legitimate civil war
does the military step in i'm truly
concerned but hopeful
we end this reign of idiocy yeah
i have said before i am worried about
violence in the streets
if trump loses narrowly and claims
it was rigged i am very worried about
that
uh and um we we have to hope
that our systems are strong enough to
resist that
and um i i will leave it to you
to figure out if that's the case hold on
we ha i have to drop a few banhammers
um these are happening both on twitch
and youtube
um my god just some disgusting people
truly vile people coming through my
various streams
and we are uh we are dropping the ban
hammer there
uh okay we are now at let me see 12.99
puts us at 86. you know let i'll do a
few phone calls i
i've got about 10-15 minutes i'll just
do it because i think it's good to hear
from people and
um it seems like you know it's just a
good thing to do
so if you want to talk to me get on my
discord
at davidpakman.com discord go into the
waiting lobby
and please set to do not disturb
do not disturb so that we don't hear the
little dinging of discord constantly
and listen on i am connecting so that
you can hear
me in the waiting lobby on discord
please
only listen there because if you listen
on the stream and i call on you you're
going to be very distracted and confused
so let's just listen to a few different
people uh
people's thoughts let's go to anna
from switzerland anna from switzerland
you are on
anna from switzerland hello how are you
i'm very fine
so good to talk to you um first of all i
am not american and i wish everyone
all the best for next tuesday indeed
whole europe and i think the whole world
is worried what's going on
yeah i have a question because of the
millions of uh sent in
ballots and as mr trump
always said there will be a rigged
election
right my first thought was where are
all these ballots who is securing them
who is taking care that
nothing is taken or you know you're
saying after the ballots are submitted
and they're sitting somewhere who is
securing them at that point
yes you know each each city each town
has its own process
and uh you know it's certainly
conceivable
that these are not equally safe
processes
everywhere but you know the reality is
there have not even been allegations
that ballots are being stolen or
whatever once they're at election center
so i don't i don't want to put
an unfounded fear in people's minds that
doesn't seem warranted
i know it was just a thought yeah
because
if i would like to rig i would target
this
part of the process right no i i think
all aspects of the system need to be uh
hardened up uh unaware in switzerland
are you
um close to zurich close to zurich i've
been to zurich and i've been to
lugano have you been there oh yes
isn't it a beautiful it's a magical
place
yes it is all right anna i hope to get
back to switzerland
soon i appreciate hearing from you
please yes and all the best
all right thank you anna from
switzerland very exciting
all right let's go next to matthew from
chicago
matthew from chicago you are uh
for some reason i can't oh there we go
here matthew from chicago you were on
hey david hi ken how are you doing hey
i'm loving life
um so i actually had i've had the same
question
for a few weeks now wow i hope it's not
outdated by now
no it's not so um clearly i live in
chicago so i have
uh lori lightfoot liberal as our mayor
and then you know we've got a democratic
governor
um what is your response to people like
how trump says it all the time my very
conservative family says it all the time
when they say you know oh look at all
the
democratic-run cities that are just run
so poorly crime is high
price poverty is high but
i mean really the way i see it i'm not
the biggest fan of lori lightfoot but i
mean she does a very good job
i couldn't see a way that most
republicans would do it better
yeah no listen that's not the issue this
is a garbage talking point this is pond
scum
okay this is this is it's it's garbage
it's literal garbage
here's the reality cities
just tend to be run by democrats some
high crime cities are run by democrats
and some low crime cities are run by
democrats fewer cities are run by
republicans
and some of them have high crime and
some of them have low crime there is no
actual correlation between crime levels
when you account for the fact that
cities in general are done run by
democrats
because democrats tend to prefer to live
in cities now at the same time
if you compare what what's really
interesting is
uh republicans tend to be in charge
of more rural areas and if you look okay
if you look at some random tiny town
uh there's there may be little crime and
it's run by republicans and it looks
very good but if you look at some of
these lower population density
counties on a per capita basis the crime
is off the charts what they
are counting on is that we won't think
about it
on a per capita basis but you really
have to look at
areas of similar total populations
the numbers look very different it's a
garbage complete garbage talking point i
have a whole youtube clip about it you
can look at
okay thanks man yeah all right thank you
appreciate the phone call
that uh that that's it's it's just a
bad bad bad talking point let's go
next to uh why don't we go to
kent jr from kentucky kent jr from
kentucky are on the air
hello david can you hear me i can hear
you okay so
i'm a teenager from kentucky okay i just
wanted to get on here
to urge everyone who if they're not
gonna vote
think about your kids or others people
kids because we don't have that right to
vote
and it's really disheartening when
people have that right
yeah but they don't use it and it's just
very it's very sad
oh it's more than it's a tragedy it's a
tragedy we
55 can can you imagine kent jr
55 turnout in 2016.
45 didn't vote that's insane
it's it's completely insane now in
kentucky
what's going on from the standpoint of
masks are you seeing masks out on the
street
okay so i live in a town that's about 15
minutes away from a major city
yeah um in my little town
very very few masks races are rampant
right now it's crazy
um in the city 15 minutes away lexington
kentucky there's a lot of masks
most of them um but something i wanted
to mention to you was something i found
really crazy
yeah is that in my town i'm actually
seeing more biden
hair signs than i am trump signs wow do
you want to say what town that is i
don't want it i don't want to dox you
but
pierce kentucky pierce kentucky wow well
listen
um i don't think biden's going to win
kentucky but if it's closer than it was
in 2016 it's still a
bad sign for trump i totally agree with
you and also
i've seen way more trump advertisements
on tv
than buying advertisements and it makes
you wonder are they spending their money
in the right places
well yeah right right or do they need to
spend money in kentucky imagine that
yeah that would be crazy too hey so how
old a guy are you
i am about turn 16. we have a 15 year
old
ladies and gentlemen having to tell
adults
you should really go and vote understand
the problems we have in this country
that 15 year olds are having to call in
and say
hey you might want to vote ken i really
appreciate the call
thank you for your time david all right
kent jr respectful young man
telling people they have to vote
unbelievable unbelievable
let's go to my caller from san luis
obispo or as i say
san luis obispo i can't actually see
your name uh it
is it billy
yes billy from san luis obispo you're on
the air
hey david how you doing hear me hey i
didn't hear you brother i listened to
you all the time i
never thought i had in a million years i
could have talked to you thank you uh
yeah hey um
actually you know i took my mask off
please don't tell anybody
i'm supposed to eat with it on and uh
you know never take it off right some
people so
um okay now in all so so what what
billy's referring to is that trump said
this morning or yesterday
you you in california you even have to
eat through the mask do you even know
like what he was wrongly referring to
no i mean you're asking me to to
go into the inner workings of i don't
even want to go there i don't know i'm
asking you to make sense of nonsense
yeah he's he's just being uh
hyperbolic yes if he even knows what how
to do that
right uh he's probably just being
himself uh anyways look
with all of the voter suppression going
on um you know we're hearing about it in
all these states
yeah and whatnot my question was really
what can
you know putting the not putting the car
before the horse but assuming biden
wins this year or in four years maybe a
democrat wins
what can they do at a i know the
president
the the elections are run at state
levels but what can a president or uh do
to help states not
uh restrict voting rights yeah
it's a very good question and the answer
is different depending on
who is in the white house who controls
the house and senate
and what is the party that controls the
governorship
and state legislature and unfortunately
that it's a very complex sort of set of
of
facts and figures there but um what i
would look at
initially is look at some of the
proposals that did pass the house
to deal with election suppression voter
suppression
and of course the senate never even took
up there's a lot of ideas in there and a
lot of them are relatively
you know bureaucratic and administrative
in nature but i think
in order to really answer that question
first we'll have to see what kind of a
deck we're playing with in terms of who
controls what and then we'll have to
work backwards from there
yeah i know i hear you so probably
reading those bills is maybe a little
dry but yeah i guess it does it hinges
not only on the presidency though but at
some point
absolutely some kind of control in the
senate oh my god 100
just dying on that table yeah oh that
kind of leaves me
if you don't mind yeah well you know you
always say you know what you know we
gotta get the football back
you know we gotta not football but the
ball back the ball yeah
apply it to whatever sport you want sure
i like to play it to football
yeah um you know in this analogy what
i'm thinking is supposing we get the
ball back
i mean we're playing with 10 men
versus 13 and the refs are
paid off and i just don't see how much
you know can we even score points at
this point
i love the analogy we will have to fix
the rules of the game to be fair
in order to get points on the board
seems to be what you were saying
yeah yeah i mean it's it's all you know
the courts have been
completely stacked by mitch uh and now
the supreme court
and uh you know and all these crazy
executive orders
which most of them are garbage but yeah
just all of the stuff that that's been
um you know that they're
not playing fairly essentially and now
uh
what we have to just spend four years
almost undoing all that just to get the
game a lot of work to do a lot of work
to do you're correctly pointing it out
billy listen i love san luis obispo
i've been two questions for you number
one
do you view people who hang out in pismo
beach as kind of hippies or weirdos
uh no i don't no i don't think so pismos
i mean it's obviously touristy
yeah um i think i think the um so i grew
up also in fresno which is
just a two-hour drive from here yeah and
it gets incredibly hot there in the
summer
yep so i i think that the more
you know generalization is that people
that go to pismo are
you know tourists from fresno got it you
know got it uh but it doesn't
generally strike me as i mean if any
place is hip
hippie or hipstery even is it's san luis
obispo
oh right no so to be clear i was
familiar with pismo as an old
hippie place not hipster like from the
seventies oh sure
uh but okay and then in either case i
mean i'm sure there's some old burn out
they're smoking in their bw vans right
it's not generally yeah now when i was
in in san luis obispo
one of my favorite coffee shops in the
united states
is in downtown san luis obispo i want
you to help me remember the name it's
it's
large and kind of cavernous and it's
called either like
like cat cat it's not katzenberg
there's crewsberg crewsberg that's
exactly right
is that please tell me it's not oh my
god they're gone you're telling me this
is
they're still there they're still
downtown just not on the same street
that they used to be
so oh but they're still there but
there's quite a few other coffee shops
um surprisingly there's like one on
every corner and i'm always like wow
like how can they do well
yeah but um you know people love their
coffee and there's another one downtown
if you ever hear uh called kin that i
really like downtown
um and they're new but they have a
really good
um really good uh brew
i love it love it and and you're telling
me cruzberg
moved in the last year um
they've they relocated
within the last couple years okay so
maybe i saw the new location
yeah probably it's possible all right
all right billy from
slo great to hear from you today hey
thanks david
uh take care man you too there it is
billy uh all right and let's see who
else we can hear from here because there
are just
so many people anxiously just desperate
to get on
um and you know it can get it can get
pretty aggressive sometimes let me go to
um let me go to moises
from malden
hey how you doing hey pretty good pretty
good um i just want to say
first off um i really really enjoy your
show
i really have been the past year just
learning a lot from your show and i'm
really really glad that thank you for
everything that you do um i just had a
quick
question about immigration i
find it that a lot of people when they
talk about immigration especially mostly
from the right
they talk as if immigrants are coming in
to take over as if they're these vile
people but they always seem to ignore
the cold war or what i'd like to call
the
cold war era policies that led to
a lot of these nations just um
being in poverty and creating a lot of
uh the direct and
indirect effects of uh mass
or just illegal immigration i'm just
wondering um
have you found any anybody on the right
bringing bringing that argument up is it
something that they just want to ignore
or i have not heard anyone on the right
talking about that there are lots of
really good
academic resources debunking a lot of
the
sort of failed anti-immigration talking
points a common one is
listen if you bring in a bunch more
people who want jobs
salaries go down and native workers lose
their jobs
and of course what they ignore is
they're making a supply side argument
while ignoring the fact that if you
bring in a bunch more people
you increase demand for housing you
increase demand for groceries you
increase demand for computers and local
products and you're stimulating
the demand side as well and once you
understand that
you can very easily see through a lot of
the bad anti-immigration arguments but
no i've never heard
specifically what you're talking about
addressed by the right
yeah because i find it that we it seems
like i said that they want to treat
these people
almost in a vacuum it's almost as if
they form questions and they form these
arguments
in a way that if outside if you don't
understand
context and history yes it seems as if
of course
like the logical answer would be like of
course we it would
without any compassion is what i'm
saying a lot of the
the idea the economic ideas of the right
as you're pointing out makes sense
if you don't understand anything like
for example hey
uh if you give the rich a tax cut
the money trickles down like if you
apply no critical thinking whatsoever
maybe that makes sense
but then when you do it all of a sudden
does doesn't make very much sense so
you've really figured out
the the crux of of disabusing oneself of
these
bad arguments yeah
well uh yeah that was my question uh
again thank you
for everything and uh great to get to
listen to you david all right moises
from malden very much appreciate hearing
from you
all right guys that does it for me we
didn't get to a hundred
but i still took some calls but now i'm
gonna go
all right so i'll see everybody later